I'm here in Palo Alto California with
Divya nog who is the co-founder of
stem-cell therapy no sticks so let's
start with the word theranostics what
what does that mean
so theranostics is kind of the
combination of therapeutics and
diagnostics and so what do you what do
you guys do what is what is stem cells
are not six mission so recreate a
technology to take skin cells turn them
into stem cells and then we could turn
those stem cells into any cell of the
body we chose to turn them into beating
heart cells on a dish and you can take
those stem cells on the dish and you can
do clinical trials on those cells in a
dish that's right so the really cool
part about our technology is we can take
these heart the skin cells from any
patient in the United States or in the
world actually and their heart cells
will actually contain all the same
genetic and ethnic information as the
patient so what we essentially have is a
clinical trial because we have thousands
of patients worth of cells on these
dishes where we can test drugs on them
to see whether or not one they're fatal
for the heart or to whether or not they
actually have the intended effects and
but the ultimate even more beyond that
you can when you have a heart attack or
something happens to your heart your
heart gets damaged and the the goal or
the hope is that eventually you'll be
able to take these stem cells and heart
stem cells and inject them back into the
heart that's right so that's a
therapeutic aspect after heart attack
several of your heart cells die and
currently your body has no way of
actually regenerating those heart cells
so what we can do is easily take your
skin cells turn them into your own
beating heart cells and then inject them
back into the heart to repair
functionality and so eventually to do
this you're gonna have to do clinical
trials at a big scale and you're you're
a small start-up here you have a grant
from the state of California but you
can't afford to do a massive thing so
you're gonna have to partner with
somebody right that's right that's kind
of where the top ten big pharmaceutical
companies come into play they have the
deep pockets they don't necessarily have
the means of innovating themselves but
when it comes time for us to spend
millions and millions of dollars on
clinical trials a little partner with
one of them so we're actually sitting in
the space we're not in your labs we're
sitting in the space is this Stanford's
accelerator Stanford University's
accelerator and you or your comp
was the first medical company to go
through this program that's right so
we're sitting in startx which is an
accelerator program for Stanford
students and typically startx sees a lot
of IT companies come in both in the
consumer space and enterprise space and
so our company is on the reserve and so
we were the first one of the first
biotech companies to come through the
program and we saw kind of right off the
bat how different it is to start a
medical company than an IT company where
you know really all you need is a table
and a computer whereas we need a lab
space had to deal with regulatory issues
such as the FDA and it's just a very
very different experience but you've now
you personally have gone on to start
with in startx
a sort of subsidiary X program called
start X med right which is very tailored
towards medical entrepreneurs so we
support digital health companies biotech
companies medical devices count the
entire gamut and the mission is really
to help support these medical
entrepreneurs by creating a
collaborative environment where they can
really talk about their successes and
failures and use care of this community
and crowdsourcing method of advancing
their own companies so stem cells are
one of those things that everybody's
been hearing about for a while now over
a decade it's I mean it's but it sounds
like this magical miracle we can grow
anything right how far away are we from
seeing actual in your opinion seen
actual products being delivered to
consumers that are based on stem cells I
think we're really close one of the
problems or one of the reasons why stem
cells haven't been as widely adopted so
far is because there were some ethical
concerns regarding the use of embryonic
stem cells but now that we have
technologies such as stem cells they're
gnostics where we can literally create
the stem cells out of your skin cells
out of your fat cells we completely buy
we completely bypass all the ethical
concerns and some self there gnostics
product is already on the market we
already have customers and so I think
we're gonna see a huge influx of more
amazing stem cell based technologies
coming out so you dropped out of
Stanford you were publishing very high
level academic papers and you started
this company and you decided not to
it was school what would you would you
tell other people to go that route or
what was going through your head to me
that's a big decision you were at
Stanford you were doing great work and
you made this decision it was probably
one of the hardest and easiest decisions
I've ever had to make I always tell
people that are kind of considering
dropping out that if you have to
consider it it's probably not the best
thing for you I was at a point where our
technology just was so promising and I
was so passionate about it that nothing
else kind of made sense to me and it was
very clear that this is what I wanted to
do so I think if you have that kind of
burning passion where you'll know it
okay that makes sense we all have a
minute left so if you can fast forward I
know this is kind of an impossible task
but fast forward five years and your
your head
what are you doing is stem-cell therapy
doing the same thing you're still
working on cardiac issues or are you
moved on to something else yeah so I
think in five years of course biotech
moves very slowly but I definitely
imagine us being in clinical trials
where we're actually testing our
products in actual patients and we have
a vision of really expanding beyond just
cardiac we want to start creating brain
cells and liver cells and kidney cells
and really trying to see kind of what
the full potential of stem cell
technologies